ويود الجميع هنا أن يرانا
نضع حداً لهذا الصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني ، حيث
تظهر حقيقة أن العديد من
القادة والخبراء العالميين في الاستثمار جاءوا
من جميع أنحاء العالم أن
هناك رغبة جادة في الاهتمام
واستعدادًا من قبل المجتمع العالمي
لمساعدة  الشعب الفلسطيني ، إذا كان من
الممكن إنشاء السياق الصحيح لفترة طويلة جدًا ، فإن
الشعب الفلسطيني محاصر في
إطار غير فعال من الماضي ، فإن
رؤية الكهنة للازدهار هي إطار حديث
لمستقبل أكثر
إشراقًا وازدهارًا ، إنها رؤية لما
هو ممكن مع  السلام ،
الحكمة التقليدية حول مصير
الفلسطينيين متسقة بشكل ملحوظ في
اجتماع بعد اجتماع ومؤتمر
بعد مؤتمر ، أسمع نفس
السجل المحطم للسلبية حول
سبب عدم إمكانية التقدم عندما سألت
نظرائي عن سبب استمرارهم في
تكرار نفس نقاط الحديث حول الإطار  على الرغم من عدم وجود
دليل على أنها تؤدي إلى التقدم ، إلا أنهم
يقولون ذلك ولكننا قلنا دائمًا هذه الأشياء
و  نحن نبيع عندما نقوم دائمًا
بالأشياء بهذه الطريقة بينما يتشدق السياسيون
بأن العالم يتحرك للأمام ولا
يزال الشعب الفلسطيني
متخلفًا عن الركب ، نتفق جميعًا على
الأهداف التالية التي نريد أن نرى السلام
والأمن والازدهار للفلسطينيين
الفلسطينيين والإسرائيليين والجميع  في
جميع أنحاء العالم نريد الحرية
للناس للعبادة دون
اضطهاد نريد أن يعيش الناس
معًا بكرامة واحترام
ونريد أن نخلق حياة أفضل
لأطفالهم وللأجيال القادمة أن
يكون النمو الاقتصادي الواضح والازدهار
للشعب الفلسطيني  غير
ممكن بدون
حل سياسي دائم وعادل للصراع ، حل
يضمن أمن إسرائيل
ويحترم كرامة الشعب الفلسطيني ،
لكن اليوم لا يتعلق
بالقضايا السياسية التي سنصل إليها في
الوقت المناسب ، والهدف من هذه الورشة هو
أبدأ التفكير في هذه التحديات
بطريقة جديدة ، رسالتي المباشرة
للشعب الفلسطيني هي ذلك  على الرغم من أن
أولئك الذين خذلوك في الماضي
أخبروك أن الرئيس ترامب وأمريكا
لم يتخلوا عنك ، فهذه
الورشة بالنسبة لك ، فإن الرؤية التي طورناها
وأطلقناها إذا تم تنفيذها بشكل صحيح ستؤدي
إلى مستقبل أفضل للشعب الفلسطيني ...
الكرامة
والازدهار والفرصة ، يمكنك تغيير
مسارك إلى الجانب الإيجابي إذا كنا على
استعداد لتجربة أشياء جديدة والتفكير
خارج الصندوق التقليدي